الان الى التطورات على الحدود اللبنانيه
الاسرائيليه افاد مراسل الجزيره باطلاق
اكثر من 20 صاروخا من جنوب لبنان باتجاه
مواقع عسكريه اسرائيليه بين مستوطنتي
زرعيت وتوله في الجليل الاعلى كما اعلن
حزب الله استهداف تجمعات للجنود
الاسرائيليين في محيط ثكنه شميرا وكان حزب
الله اعلن امس انه استهدف بالصواريخ
سته مستوطنات اسرائيليه واربعه مواقع
عسكريه قبال الحدود الجنوبيه كما قصفت
الطائرات والمدفعيه الاسرائيليه خلال
الساعات الماضيه محيط اكثر من 20 بلده
جنوب لبنان للمزيد بهذا الشان معنا من
ارميش جنوب لبنان مدير مكتب الجزيره مازن
ابراهيم ومن الجليل الاعلى مرسلتنا فاطمه
خميسي اذا مازن وفاطمه اهلا بكم ابدا معك
مازن لتضع في صوره ما يجري من
الجانب اللبناني
تفضل في الواقع ليلى سياق التصعيد الذي
نراقبه ونرص منذ عده ايام يبدو انه مستمر
اليوم من خلال اطلاق هذه المجموعه الكبيره
من الصواريخ عند الساعه الثامنه والنصف
بالتوقيت المحلي هنا في لبنان حيث رصدنا
اطلاق اكثر من 20 صاروخا من الواضح ان
استخدام راجمات الصواريخ بات تكتيكا
يعتمده حزب الله في مهاجمه المواقع
الاسرائيليه هذه صواريخ انصبت باتجاه محيط
اربعه مستوطنات ضمن القطاع الاوسط من جنوب
لبنان وبعدما صدر بيان حزب الله قبل قليل
ويشير فيه الى
استهداف هذه المواقع الاسرائيليه وتحديدا
ثكنه شميرا فان هذا الامر يشي باننا ازاء
يوم متجدد من الاستهدافات التي افتتحها
حزب الله اليوم من خلال هذا الهجوم على
هذه الثكنه وهذه الصواريخ الكبيره التي تم
اطلاقها ضمن مجموعه كبيره من الصواريخ
عمليا ما يحصل اليوم ياتي في سياق نرصده
منذ عده ايام من تصعيد متواصل بالامس
تحدثنا عن عشر عمليات نفذها حزب الله وكان
العنوان الرئيسي فيها استهداف المستوطنات
الاسرائيليه يوم امس ست مستوطنات جرى
استهدافهم بالصواريخ المباشره نتحدث عن
المطله نتحدث عن مجموعه كبيره من من هذه
من كريات شموه من من افيف من دوفي ف
مجموعه كبيره من هذه ال المستوطنات وذلك
ضمن تكتيك بات واضحا بان حزب الله يتعامل
مع هذه المستوطنات بعدما جرى افراغها من
قبل المستوطنين وعندما قامت قوات الاحتلال
بانذار المستوطنين بمغادرتها حزب الله بت
يعتمد ويعتبر هذه المستوطنات بمثابه ثكنات
عسكريه وانطلاقا من هذه المرحله الثانيه
التي يخوض فيها المواجهات فهو لم يعد
يقتصر باطلاق القذائف والقنابل والصواريخ
باتجاه المواقع العسكريه الاماميه عند
الحافه الاماميه للحدود اللبنانيه ولكن
اصبح استهداف المستوطنات في عمقها وذلك في
محاوله لالحاق اكبر قدر ممكن من الاصابات
وهنا لابد من الاشاره باننا ازاء كلفه
بشريه باهظه على المستوى اللبناني نتحدث
منذ اندلاع هذه المواجهات في الثامن من
اكتوبر عن اكثر من 24 شهيدا سقطوا في
لبنان من المدنيين بالاضافه الى اعلان حزب
الله عن استشهاد 115 من مقاتليه في هذه
المواجهات وبالتالي الامور مرشحه للتصعيد
لا سما ان الغارات الاسرائيليه بعجاله
الليله باتت تصل الى عمق كبير داخل جنوب
لبنان وهي لا تقتصر على قصف الشريط
الحدودي سواء من خلال المسيرات المقاتلات
الحربيه او حتى الصواريخ الموجهه بالاضافه
الى المدفعيه شكرا مازن اذهب الى فاطمه
الان لت طلعنا على ما تقوله
اسرائيل نعم يعني بالفعل على الرغم من
ظروف الطقس الصعبه وكميه الضباب من خلفي
الا ان حزب الله نجح بشن عمليه جدا واسعه
نتحدث عن رصد اكثر من 20 صاروخ كما اسلف
الزميل مازن باتجاه الجليل الغربي حتى هذه
اللحظه لم يتم الابلاغ عن وجود اصابات او
وجود سقوط للصواريخ في مناطق ماهوله او في
مناطق مفتوحه في الجليل الغربي ولكن
صفارات الانذار دوت بشكل متواصل لمده
دقائق في مناطق متفرقه حدوديه في الجليل
الغربي نتحدث عن بلده شتوه الحدوديه بلده
زرعيت الحدوديه واللافت ان المجموعات
العبريه الاخباريه تتناقل ان هنالك حدث
امني خطير في الجبهه الشماليه جراء هذه
الدفعه الصاروخيه وعلى ما يبدو ان حذر
النشر وفرض الرقابه العسكريه على هذا
الحدث ستطلع ن لربما في الساعات المقبله
عن تفاصيل هذه الدفعه الصاروخيه وما ان
كانت بالفعل قد تسببت في اضرار وفي اصابات
بشريه ام ان الاضرار ستقتصر
على مباني والممتلكات العامه او ان
الدفاعات الجويه اعترضت هذه الصواريخ
نتحدث عن صواريخ مضاده للدروع باتجاه
مواقع عسكريه واللافت ايضا ان ال التعامل
مع هذه الاحداث متتاليه سواء من البارحه
وحتى هذه اللحظه الاعلام الاسرائيلي يقول
ان حزب الله بات يستهدف مواقع سكنيه
ومنازل معينه لكي يقوم بالرد على وتفعيل
معادله المدني مقابل المدني لاسما وان
مازن ذكر ان هنالك 24 شهيد من الجانب
اللبناني المدني ولذلك حزب الله يبحث عن
تسجيل اصابات في صفوف المدنيين
الاسرائيليين منذ بدء هذه المعركه في
الثامن من اكتوبر الماضي تم تسجيل فقط
مقتل اربعه اسرائيليين مدنيين وتسع جنود
في الجيش الاسرائيلي بالتوازي مع ذلك
هنالك فقط في هذا السياق نتحدث عن ايضا
تحويل هذه المنازل للاسرائيليين الى ثكنات
عسكريه يتحصن بها الجنود لذلك حتى هذه
اللحظه ليس من المعروف هل بالفعل يتم
استهداف منازل يتحصن بها الجنود او ان
بالفعل حزب الله يبحث الى تطبيق هذه
المعادله المدني مقابل
المدني لافت بالفعل اسرائيل تركز على هذا
من خلال وسائل اعلاميه اشكرك فاطمه جزيلا
واشكر طبعا مازن ابراهيم من رمش